what's happening there reject nation so
this trailer actually dropped at uh
midnight yesterday but uh i was at a
wedding did it get back to like two in
the morning we can't deplete whether or
not we should do it but ultimately we
said
nope
you
you with the jokes almost a million
subscribers later and man the jokes just
keep staying strong jordan peels nope
let's watch this hit the like button
there's more super bowl crap maybe to
come
[Music]
did you know the very first assembly of
photographs to create a motion picture
was a two second clip of a black man on
a horse my bridge and that man is my
great great grandfather great there's
another great grandfather
interesting but that's why back at the
haywood ranch as the only black owned
horse trainers in hollywood we like to
say since the moment pictures could move
yeah skin of the game
[Music]
key power is a fantastic actress by the
way
[Music]
interesting oh no
a little shining lover
oh
my nipples are so hard
hey frank's a bad mirror
oh it's a bad miracle oh
they got word for that
stephen young
oh [ __ ]
hell yeah
whack your bible too man
oh my god
damn
you know i heard speculation a while ago
that this movie might deal with aliens
and uh that is definitely dealing with
their languages that's gotta be aliens
for sure aliens are some kind of
non-terrestrial creature life yeah all
right john uh talk while i skim the
footage since we are short on time we
gotta do some one take man i love this i
mean i i appreciate that jordan peele is
really able to with each of his movies
give us and especially the trailers
these things that are so distinct and
vivid and yet leave you thinking what on
earth is actually at the core of this
and this does look maybe a little more
straightforward than us and maybe a
little less straightforward than get out
so it's cool that like you know we'll
see him in a kind of different mode
again but still informed by his previous
works i love the look of the cast and
and yeah like definitely a sort of alien
vibe because you're in this rural
setting and i love that they're going
into a little bit of hollywood history
having them be like yeah these black
horse trainers and stuff like that which
is its own culture in cinema and
hollywood and movie history and all that
stuff yeah it looks like even two
pulling that like my bridge clip at the
very beginning this might you know as
much as it's dealing with its own horror
story here dive into certain aspects of
cinema that are a little more off the
beaten path than just say the kinds of
horror movie tribute sequences that
we've seen and get out and us so uh yeah
like this looks like a really wonderful
expansion i love that we got like daniel
kaluuya back because it's you know part
of his growing troupe of performers but
we've also got some new faces in here
you point out kiki palmer and then
stephen younes in here too speaking of
steven yun he's in um what was that
movie with um like keith stanfield
started to bother you yes yes sorry to
bother you you know you're seeing all
this horse imagery here and you're
dealing with aliens and i'm wondering if
we're gonna be doing like some human
experiments jordan peele's already dealt
with that so much with the body [ __ ]
with get out and both with us human
experimentation if you're doing you know
aliens come into a desert land some form
of abduction and they had this shot here
that i was slowing down on where was it
it looked like some type of horse human
hybrid like it was his hand right here
did you see that with the little baby
hand yeah the little baby little
creature thing like yeah so i don't know
if it's like they're doing some type of
jeans splicing when it comes to is it
because i you know unless they start to
bother you i brought that up spoilers
there's this whole plot line in there
besides big spoilers that uh deals a lot
with you know turning the humans into
horses to advance it's like a big
metaphor for slave workers in a lot of
ways and you know it's jordan peele who
often often does social commentary
within his horror i could seem to him in
a similar route but if he's doing kind
of the same thing this doesn't look like
he would have any of that like humorous
satire effect into it this looks like
maybe just straight up body horror more
cronenberg level where the cronenberg
who would often go into camp this
doesn't look like it would devolve into
camp but it looks more human so i'm
wondering if it's actually kind of a
reverse process of what sorry bothered
you did where instead of taking humans
and turning them into horses if they're
taking horses and turning them into
humans maybe maybe yeah maybe they what
if there's some kind of alien creature
maybe in its attempt to assimilate it
somehow approximates both because it
lands in this place with both humans and
horses in close proximity actually the
fry's electronics both uh your family
and my dad loved shopping at fryzo look
did they close down they are closed i
just drove past the one near here and
the signs down yeah it's this uh fries
which has a big alien side yeah like
it's like literally probably like 10
minutes away from where you live yeah
but you used to go there all the time in
fact my dad was once blacklisted there
for like a short period of time it's
kind of a funny story going to some
other time but they honor a lot of like
old sci-fi or in there they even would
have like statue memorabilia of what's
the one with the cradling of the oh from
the day the earth is still yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah but they also have like a
ufo crashing through there's a lot of
like
the worlds uh you know mars attacks type
of
uh
flare
and atomic age sci-fi stuff and then
also dealing with the fact of like you
know like this character kiki palmer and
then uh daniel kaluuya talking about the
origination of motion pictures is
actually a black person well you know
yet they don't get the credit they're
deserved so i don't really know i don't
feel like i'm well versed enough to
properly comment thoroughly on how the
implementation of the commentary might
be infused in here uh but yeah this
looks like a more disturbing version of
science mixed in with some of that
traditional jordan appeal commentary
with a blend of riley boots is sorry to
bother you yeah
yeah
if this could be his signs i can't wait
to hear all the debates surrounding it
i'm wondering like stephen young seems a
little bit more like the sharkish person
like he's even offering up a horse here
in this one shot yeah
and he's i'm wondering if stephen young
might be playing against typecasting a
little bit because you would kind of
expect him to not be the [ __ ]
somewhere if he will be a little bit
more of that like
hotter than cowboy
one and what is it with those wacky
waving inflatable arm flailing tube men
because i mean he's got him at the car
lot but it also there's that one
sequence where they show up all over the
field you know that looks like it's on
their property so is that going to
become some kind of demented omen of
dark deeds to come well look at this guy
on the motorcycle shot you could see
this circle yeah i don't know what that
is there's a lot of like ufo imagery
yeah yeah which makes me wonder too if
that could be a subversion maybe he
wants us to think it's a ufo it's gonna
be something different but but that when
she gets swept up into this guy that
looks pretty amazing textbook ufo i
don't know where this fry's electronics
place would be for i don't know i don't
know where this service takes place
because i mean looking at this i feel
like it's taking place in the earlier
part of
it doesn't look like
it's like it's 202
it looks like it's probably earlier 2000
yeah maybe i mean and it looks you know
sort of removed like it's maybe mid
state california or something like that
so sure especially if you're dealing
with hollywood yeah six places spawn
ranch
yeah let's get bruce dern in here all
right guys well thanks so much for being
here uh watch kiki palmer on euphoria
she's fantastic
hey subscribe click that bell hit that
like button we'll catch you all soon